my dear friend
i seem to have found myself in the most
enchanting of places
[Music]
azoria is everything i'd hoped it would
be
a simple life where i can care for the
land
in a beautiful world it's a place to
belong
every day i explore something new
there's so much to do i wish i had time
for it all
luckily i have friends here
and everyone plays a part to cultivate
this world we all share
i can see it now
the more we try the more we'll discover
the more we build the more we'll grow
there's a certain kind of magic to it
the way things all come together
[Music]
that brings me to azaria's best kept
secret
there is real magic here
bay magic that you must see to believe
who knows what secrets are waiting just
be on our realm
of course every adventure has its
dangers
but we'll face those together
[Music]
that's why i'm writing to you
if you ever feel that longing for
something more
know that it's waiting for you here
and so am i
i hope to see you soon
[Applause]
you